things between pedro and i are not okay
i don't know the family chantelle star
chantelle everett and pedro hamino call
it quits it's news that's rocking the
90-day fiance universe according to
court docs obtained by e.t pedro filed
for divorce back in may but those
weren't the only papers served we've
learned a mutual restraining order was
filed the same day pedro well i'm
convinced that there is nothing that i
can do to change your mind about me you
don't like me while a surprise this
isn't a total shock fans have watched
chantal and pedro head towards
separation on the latest season of their
spin-off you don't love it you know you
you don't you know you don't you don't
just say it you know just say it you
know just say you don't like me and you
don't love you you know what when
you don't tell me that you do love me
why don't you tell me how you really
feel
after a heated argument viewers saw
their relationship continue to unravel
it all went downhill when chantel
confronted pedro about a possible affair
with his co-worker when i ask you where
you're going you're telling me it's none
of my business and you're coming home
drunk i photograph see what [ __ ] on you
i left the house a long time ago she
also accused pedro of being just like
his father who had a past of infidelity
which led to his dad having a whole
other family outside of his marriage to
pedro's mom
it seems like pedro is starting to
follow in the same footsteps of his
father he's treating me poorly just like
his father treated his wife
and
his mistress he's disrespecting women
that's what his father was all about
disrespecting women their tlc spin-off
is the first of its kind to follow a
single couple from the 90-day franchise
and it seems like we might get answers
this season on what ultimately led to
the paris demise and there are a lot of
questions because less than a year ago
chantel told et they were trying for a
baby we know that pedro's been pushing
to start a family too
is that something you see on the horizon
for you too
yeah i want to have a baby i want to
um
pedro and i we just really want to be
very
strategic with the you know he analyzes
everything
everything has to be just
yeah
so
it is something that we want for both of
us you